Kinderarbeit für unsere Autos Handys und
Kosmetik ihr Hand schließlich darüber
diskutiert was man damit kann machen
unsere Alltagsprodukt der Audianer 87
zum Beispiel schreibt eine sehr
interessante aber auch erschreckende
Doku Kinderarbeit und Armut werden wir
wohl nie abschaffen können das wäre ja
Wunschdenken denn es ist ein komplexes
Thema und dass ich eigentlich die
Regierungen kümmern müssten aber leider
sind diese unfähig und korrupt und wir
toleriert schon bekämpft Lösungen habe
ich leider auch keine aber ich finde es
gut dass man sich mit dem Thema
auseinandersetzt man zum Beispiel hat
geschrieben zum Glück haben wir die
Konzern verantwortungsinitiative nicht
angenommen sonst müsste man ja auch noch
was tun Konzern verantwortlich sind
Stichwort das ist wo hat wähle das
Schweiz für ihre gesamte Verantwortung
übernehmend und drum ich mir dazu altet
schafft Führerin von der Initiative
zerreiner patzen
verpassen würde jetzt hier konzentriert
Initiative sicherstellen dass man keine
Kinder Arbeit machen
richtig komplexe Situation geht wo man
ohne den Konzern ist verantwortlich für
Zustand in der ramina sondern das Recht
Rezepte die Verantwortung ist und darum
sich nicht Erlösung
ist
an eine Lösung für ein so komplexes
Problem erarbeiten zu können ich glaube
klare Verantwortlichkeiten Engel
Zusammenarbeit mit den Menschen vor Ort
und konsequent Überprüfung der Zustände
vor Ort wäre Ansätze einer Lösung dies
wird nicht auf der Basis von guten
Willensbekundungen passieren
rund um Anschlüsse dann könnte das ist
genau der Punkt das geht nicht das der
Schutz von Menschenrechten
mit Interesse von
Konzerne
orientieren
verantwortungsgesetz
verabschiedet sie und dort ist
vorgesehen das ist einerseits
sie führen haftungsmechanismus gibt das
heißt das lied wo
Opfer sie von Menschenrecht
klar
veröffentlichen sorgfältigt ob die
Stimme oder doch
Organisationen ist auf ein Missstand und
das überprüfe und sanktionieren
vor allem vom geounterricht in Kosmetika
gilt es offenbar als nicht Gesundheit
gefährlich für den Endverbraucher gibt
es beim Abbau von Maika für die
Arbeiterinnen gesundheitliche Folgen wie
zum Beispiel die Silikose beim
quarzabbau und wäre es möglich den
Bedarf an Maika durch das im Labor
hergestellte Produkt zu ersetzen ja
danke für das und all diese Frage sehr
schnell
gilt als
gesundheitliche Risiko für Michael
Sammlerinnen will sie atmet Staubi und
das ist schlecht junge und aber nicht
exakt gehört
Rezepte vom used yourological servicide
aber ich danke für Firmen wo wenn
wirklich sagen wir haben drei
Kinderarbeit ihr ist eine Produkt mit
Maika ist es sicher gut die Alternative
will Loot responsive
wir sind die zwei größten
Madagaskar und die beiden auch in der
Arbeit ein andere Möglichkeit für Firmen
ganz klar Kinder
abends andere Länder importieren z.B die
USA die hat auch recht aber das hat mir
Experte vom logical Servicezeit dass du
nicht zu sehr sehr kurz mager exportiert
höhere Lohnkosten in der USA ist das
Michael
vergleichsmäßig viel Dürer als das
Madagaskar
wirst du noch Fragen
dann dürfte Krisen Auslöser das hat auch
Chefin von der Firma mir gesagt
eigentlich
sagen mir probiert vor Ort kaufen aber
darum noch garantieren
wie könnten oder sollten englisches wie
solche in der Dokumentation sich aus
deiner Sicht weiterentwickeln um stärker
zum Schutz von Kindern beizutragen und
mit LP fragt warum sollten wir
wohlhabende Europäer den anderen Ländern
und Gesellschaften vorschreiben was
legal bzw
illegal sein soll wir waren bis vor
einigen Jahrzehnten genauso mich würde
die sich der indischen Behörden
interessieren und was hat es sich mit
den Rebellengruppen auf sich sind die
einfach im illegalen Abbau beteiligt
oder steckt da noch mehr dahinter
Kinderarbeit zu der schlimmsten
internationaler Abkommen
und das heißt das Geld verlangte auf der
ganzen Welt
nicht so sehr abgelegene Gegenden
unterrichten zum anderen
und auch immer wieder
Behörden bekämpfe das geht ab und zu
tödliche zusammen
und das führt natürlich noch weiter dazu
dass sie so bitte
ja in Ruhe und dir reale Gruppe sind
halt einfach sehr wichtig
Tätigkeit informiert der Waldmeister
schrieb eines muss sich aber ganz Europa
und auf der Rest der modernen Welt
Bewusstsein würde man die
illegalen arbeiten und Kinder Arbeiten
einstellen dann würden Produkte Preise
explodieren
ja klar und jetzt jetzt tun alles was
werden Sie betroffen und dann
interessiert es eh niemanden und alle
machen weiter
ist geil stimmt das
schrecklichen Arbeitsbedingungen und die
Finger sind bereits
und konnte
Bürokratie dass man das alles
kontrolliert und so weiter dass das
wirklich in der Arbeit hat wie jetzt
Lieferkette lang und dann heißt es wenn
man in Frankreich sollte unbedingt dann
auch wieder arbeiten
könnte und
ausgezeichnete und vielseitige Doku ich
habe davon nichts gewusst mir fehlen die
Worte ich denke wir könnten etwas
beitragen und gegen die Kinderarbeit zu
kämpfen die Frage ist wie auf Make-up
oder Harfen zu verzichten sehe ich als
sehr schwierig
die Frage gebe ich gerade mal wieder
sehr danke das ist sicherer
verantwortlich geht man mit als
konsumieren die oh hey aber die Finger
top verantwortlich liegt aber genau
bitte Konzerne und darum setze mir ist
politisch für die das ist klar die
Regler geht und da in deiner bestäubigen
sind zu dem Thema ich muss sagen ich
weiß eigentlich
ursprünglich auf das Thema hobbing aber
ich weiß dass sie dich von dem Thema
gehört haben mich mega fasziniert hat
dass man eigentlich das Material hat wo
so wichtig ist
und wann die Verbindung haben
bitte russische
mal ganz viel also alles so ein
tierpflichte etc
und ja dann haben wir Kontakt
aufgenommen
vor Ort und viele sagen ich eigentlich
sehr spontan vor Ort entstanden
große Mine schön entstanden will
und mit anonym Geschichte
[Gelächter]
[Musik]